the movie opens up as Captain Brody
Torrance is in Singapore he calls his
daughter Daniella to tell her that he
will be coming home to Honolulu for the
holidays to spend time with her Brody a
former Royal Air Force pilot is flying
Trailblazers Airlines flight 119. he
comes to meet his co-pilot Samuel Deli
who tells him they will fly through a
storm Bonnie that had flight attendant
tells Brody that he needs to meet an
RCMP officer Otis Winston the officer
tells Brody that they are moving Louis
Gaspar who is accused of killing someone
and used to be a soldier in the French
Foreign Legion as the plane gets ready
to take off we see other passengers like
a young social media star and a rude
businessman Brody and Deli talk while
they are in the air Brody tells Delhi
that his wife died years ago as the
plane flies over the South China Sea it
goes through a storm with a lot of
shaking as the storm worsens the damage
is done to the plane and Brody hurts his
head in all the chaos the RCMP officer
gets up from his seat gets tossed around
and dies a stewardess gets up from her
place to help him but she is also killed
when the plane shakes Brody and Delhi
have to keep control of the ship without
radar and radio making it safer when
they see the damage is too bad they must
quickly land the pilots find an island
and make a rough Landing everyone's
happy to be on the ground at last and
they figure out they might be on an
island in the Philippines since the
plane hasn't stopped shaking yet the
people are told to get off right away
Delhi is the first person to go down the
Escape exit followed by everyone else
Bonnie is looking over the bodies of the
Dead when Torrance tells her to stop by
Dawn everyone is safe and happy to be
off the plane the airline CEO calls a
meeting with Scarsdale a former Special
Forces officer in charge of the
operation to discuss the Trailblazers
119's disappearance when Scarsdale
learns that the flight officer prevented
Torrance from using the other route he
rebukes him for it they discovered that
the last time the plane signal was
picked up was in Manila but it was
quickly lost the officers go over the
operations for locating it in the
following scene Bonnie asks Torrance
about Gaspar and gives him the Handcuff
keys discovered while helping people off
the plane when Torrence and Delhi looked
to the map and identify where they might
have landed they discovered that it is
Jolo Island Delhi becomes cold when he
hears the name he tells Torrance that
the island is governed by a well-armed
anti-malicious with a history of murder
and robbery Torrance chooses to keep it
a secret from the other passengers to
avoid inciting fear as an alternative he
informs them that they might have
arrived in the Philippines and that they
should try to find a means to request
assistance then he assists them in
erecting a tent outside being the
gentleman that he is Sinclair objects to
their remaining inside the aircraft
Torrance responds that given the power
outage in the heat staying inside was a
big no the passengers support Torrance
and advise and Claire to be grateful for
the Pilot's accomplishments Torrance and
Delhi then try to see if they can turn
on the power again but are unable
Torrance covers the dead bodies after
entering the aircraft he investigates
the officer's back to learn more about
kaspar and then leaves after collecting
his gun Deli put some water in his
backpack while he changes into fresh
clothing it turns out that he wants to
take The Spar along as he searches for
assistance Torrance explains his
strategy to the passengers and releases
Gaspar from his handcuffs after warning
that it will take some time for help to
arrive then the two left to seek
assistance everyone continually seeks
hints at the New York headquarters but
is unsuccessful Scarsdale uses all of
his connections to assist the people in
light of the scant information
indicating they might be in the
Philippines the rescue mission is
finally given to the mercenary Black Ops
Torrance pursues Gaspar deep into the
Wilderness and quizzes him about his
motivations after discovering a pocket
knife Among Us things but a mysterious
Gaspar refuses to provide him with any
details next junmar the leader of the
anti-malisha is introduced one of the
villagers alerts him to the plane's
Landing he also informs him that it fell
close to several mines given that the
spies could not provide him with such
information Jun Mark concludes that it
could not be the Army Torrance on the
other hand is now by themselves as
Gaspar left Midway through after
repairing a few circuits he arrives at a
warehouse where he can place a call he
contacts the airlines to inform them of
the problem but the caller can only hear
him well after the line is severed
Torrance then calls his daughter
Daniella who is now very worried he then
tells her to let the companies know that
they were on the island of Jolo suddenly
someone attacks him from behind he tries
hard to get away and after a long time
of fighting Torrance is able to knock
down the person who is also trying to
grab him down he hears gunshots and gets
his gun ready at the same time when he
hears footsteps coming up from right
behind him he meets kaspar who gives him
a gun as they go down towards sees many
dead people whom Gaspard had killed then
they find a camera with a video showing
them that strangers had been robbed
there before them they rushed to the
people in the robbers van because they
fear the same thing will happen the
people get up when they hear the cars
but when they hear gunshots they realize
it's not the rescue team they were
hoping for Torrence and Gaspar get there
just as the robbers are taking over the
people they force Bonnie to give them a
list of pass passengers and ask for
torrents but no one knows who he is then
a girl tries to run away but is shot
right away her boyfriend screams for
help but he is also killed in a cruel
way the scared people are then taken off
the plane Torrance tries to help them
but Gaspar stops him because he knows it
would be stupid for the captain to go in
front of the robbers jinmar tells two of
his guys to take everything worth money
from the passengers thinkispar and
Torrance catch him and force them to
tell him what he knows then they find
out that they are going to the Village
of done delete but they're still looking
for more Torrance then returns to the
plane and finds the town on the map
after discovering that Delhi somehow
fixed The Eclectic system he leaves a
message for the rescue team so in
Scarsdale returns to the offices he
hires the mercenary Black Ops to go to
the island after checking with Daniela
on the other hand Torrance and Gaspar
get to the town where the passengers are
being held hostage slowly as they kill
off the thieves individually they meet
up with the rest of the Travelers even
though only one person was watching them
the two could get them free and get them
on boss but running away would let the
others know so Torrance risks his life
by going to confuse the robbers he says
hello to the boss and acts like he has
no idea who he is he gets hit because of
what he did at the same time the team
members start shooting at the robbers
killing many with the help of the
message they could get to the plane
quickly and catch up with the people
soon they and Torrance reach the bus in
safety June Mar is furious about what is
happening so he tells his remaining men
to go to the plane during the ride
Torrance discovers that there won't be a
relief team for another 24 hours
shellback instead asks for his help when
they get to the plane Torrance asks
everyone to believe him and get on the
plane since it's the only way they can
get out of there everyone agrees since
it's the only way out of there Torrance
asks the rescue team to help him by time
until he can fix something then jinmar
shows up in strikes hurting one of the
board members when there is a lot of
shooting both sides try their best to
win after a while Torrance is ready to
get on the plane as everyone backs him
up he runs and gets in even though
someone shoots him in one leg he tells
the offices that the plane will be flown
which Hampton disagrees with but
scardostale does inside the plane the
pilots and the rest of the team are
doing everything that they can but
shellback and Gaspar are still fighting
kaspar finds the Soldier's money back
while trying to put his gun back
together when it's time to leave
everyone gets in except Gaspar shellback
watches escaspar walks away with a bag
of money jinmar and one of his men are
still doing everything they can to stop
them jinmar's men grabs an rgf and aims
it at the plane but Gaspar kills him to
save it Torrance is pleased when he sees
the missile go in a different direction
but he is upset again when jinmar picks
up the rgf jinmar has his car parked in
front of the plane which he thinks will
stop it so he can shoot at it but
Torrance doesn't want to help so he
takes off right through them with the
help of the relief team who finally gets
in touch with the air traffic they find
a nearby airport to which the plane can
make it Torrance lands the plane safely
this time in a place where there are no
more attackers the people applaud him
and tell him how great he is everyone
gets off the plane at last click on one
of the two videos on screen right now
foreign
[Music]